françois-xavier shosha économistes à
dorval asset management monsieur ça
bonjour alors je me donnais plein de
chiffres alors mis première question est
ce que ces emplois dont on a parlé ont
été détruits de manière définitive
non c'est tout un problème de
vocabulaire dans cette crise qui est
totalement nouvelle
nos copains de récession de chômage de
masse ça correspond pas à la réalité
les statistiques s'affolent pour des
raisons bien connues en question la
fermeture de l'économie le confinement
les précautions sanitaires
aux etats unis le chômage partiel est
très peu développée donc les aides aux
salariés passent par la case chômage
mais dans la plupart des cas évidemment
on parle plutôt de congés que de que de
chômage en réalité c'est comme si vous
voulez les grandes vacances des congés
payés et on note d'ailleurs que cette
case chômage permet en fait c'est même
la condition nécessaire pour que les
salariés puissent recevoir des aides qui
sont souvent très généreuse 1 puisque
ces 600 $ de plus par semaine que le
chômage classique et c'est même plus
plus généreux que dans beaucoup de pays
européens donc vous faire attention
comparaison l'europe et est engagé dans
un système de ce qu'on appelle le
chômage partiel ou technique
là aussi les moines ont pas grand sens
mais à la fin il ne fait aucun doute que
la réouverture de l'économie et dans
l'écrasante majorité que ce soit aux
états unis ou en europe des entre
guillemets chômeurs ou chômeurs partiels
va retrouver son poste mais reste que ce
sera pas la totalité
donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
le chômage partiel ans qui est une
technique un peu louer un peu partout
dans le monde les américains aujourd'hui
n'en ont pas besoin
c'est ce sont ces cohérents avec leur
système de marché d'être avec un marché
du travail huîtres inflexible donc ça
passe par effectivement une sortie
provisoire de la société pour recevoir
les aides d'état donc c'est vraiment
plus des questions institutionnelles qui
se joue là elle est question d'habitude
mais à la fin ça regroupe exactement la
même réalité
la différence effectivement c'est que ce
sera plus facile pour les entreprises
américaines qui désirent ne pas
réembaucher
ce sera plus facile de le faire ça c'est
vrai et c'est pour ça que il faudra les
mesures d'accompagnement et de relance
pour absorber le stock donc donc on est
pas encore mais le stock des vrais
chômeurs qui va apparaître et convainc
comprendrez qu'on va mesurer au cours
des prochains mois on sait par exemple
que pour le secteur du tourisme
l'aviation les loisirs
là il y aura les vrais chômeurs et pour
les absorber
il va falloir les plans de relance
massifs ce qui est de toute façon prévu
et des soutiens et c'est donc c'est on a
devant nous deux trois ans peut-être de
plans de relance et justement quelles
sont les mesures d'accompagnement les
paons d'investissement que
l'administration trucks prévoit de
mettre en place
alors en fait sans discussion
aujourd'hui au congrès il ya une pointe
à une bataille entre le plan des
démocrates qui est plus accession de
dépenses et le plan des républicains
plus sur les baisses d'impôts pour les
entreprises l'administration américaine
voudrait des baisses d'impôts sur les
salaires donc pour l'instant il n'y a
pas de plan qui qui apparaît
consensuel mais ce consensus va arriver
très vite et il va il va produire pas
mal de l'emploi je pense et il sera
surtout accompagné de mesures
supplémentaires de la réserve fédérale
américaine vous êtes plutôt que le
chômage n'est pas un peu parti pour
s'installer dans le paysage économique
alors ça dépendra vraiment de ces plans
de relance on n'est pas dans une crise
économique il faut comprendre ça sais-tu
c'est un choc extérieur qui arrivait sur
une économie qui allait bien passé le
mot états unis très peu de chômage pas
d'inflation mais là effectivement avec
avec ce coup dur il ya beaucoup
d'entreprises qui sont plus endettés
donc oui il ya un chômage qui va arriver
du fait de ce coronavirus et qui est un
vrai chômage qui ne s'est on ne peut pas
le mesurer londres mais c'est peut-être
peut-être 5 ou 6% de la population
active aux états unis donc je le répète
pour l'absorber va falloir aller très
vite parce qu'on a vu dans d'autres
récessions à particuliers en 2008 que si
on ne va pas vite
à ce moment là en décourage un certain
nombre de salariés qui sort de la
population active
et ça ça crée des fractures sociales
donc il faudra aller très vite
la bonne nouvelle il faut être prudent
toujours mais la bonne nouvelle c'est
que la leçon 2008 a été tirée de ce côté
ci de l'atlantique comme de l'autre côté
il faut aller vite qu'il faut soutenir
les plans de relance ne pas avoir peur
de la dette pour empêcher le chaos
françois-xavier cherche à vous êtes
économiste à dorval asset management
merci pour votre éclairage